today's uh graduating bits sessions the
second of itcs uh we had one yesterday
as well if you're not familiar
graduating bits is an exciting tradition
at uh itcs in order to highlight some of
the individuals who are
new near graduation
one way or the other really highlighting
some of the outstanding young members of
the tcs community here
so today we're going to have a series of
11 lightning talks in a row
each about four minutes long and uh yeah
we'll just jump right into it the first
uh
lightning talk uh
for graduating this will be given by
sarah scheffler um at princeton and
sarah feel free to take it away whenever
you're ready
goodness all right uh so good morning
i'm sarah scheffler i'm currently a
postdoc at the center for information
technology policy at princeton
my background's in cryptography i got my
phd last year from boston university
advised by mayakvaria
i'm looking for 10-year track positions
after my current postdoc is completed uh
so my research is a mix of applied
cryptography and some interdisciplinary
law and computer science work my applied
crypto work is primarily in zero
knowledge and that's all fairly standard
stuff so i'd like to spend most of my
time talking about my interdisciplinary
law and cs work so i'm going to describe
two projects in more detail one that's
mostly completed and another that's
currently ongoing
so the first work in this area i'd like
to discuss is about compelled decryption
in the u.s
so this is when a court order someone to
decrypt their device usually by entering
their passcode
so why do we as cryptographers think we
should have any say over what the
interpretation of the law should be in
this area
well there's currently no consensus
among courts and legal scholars as to
whether or not the government can compel
people to decrypt like this
so the underlying legal doctrine was
formulated to determine when people can
be compelled to produce things like tax
documents it has to do with what is
learned by the government when someone
is compelled to do an order that might
have implicit testimony and we actually
think our definitions of knowledge and
learning and leakage that we use in
cryptography are actually a very helpful
tool to add to the toolbox to answer
this specific question
so i'm not going to get too into the
details but under this doctrine the
government can compel you to do things
it could have done without your help
based on what it already knows
but it cannot compel things that it
could potentially only learn from your
mind because this would violate the
fifth amendment
so we noticed that this concept is very
similar to the cryptographic concept of
a simulator
so you can figure out if the government
is relying on leaked testimony by
figuring out whether or not it can
simulate the results without using the
respondent's mind but using everything
else in the world
so we use this concept to analyze
several scenarios both involving
encryption and not
when we apply this method to compel
decryption we find that the government
cannot compel decryption in the general
case but this changes with the presence
of additional evidence that does often
exist in real world settings
we also introduce an idea called fc
resilience which is a security property
of a crypto system that basically asks
if its user can be compelled to reveal
the secrets used in that crypto system
that's not the end of the story but i
also want to describe some other ongoing
work about content moderation in
end-to-end encryption uh which i know is
a tricky subject uh in fact content
moderation is tricky even sort of in the
ideal condition right even so we have
constant arguments over what we should
and shouldn't do with all sorts of
categories of content and even when
there's broad support for removing a
certain kind of content or even a law
mandating it this is still a really
really complicated difficult issue
uh and the question becomes even more
challenging in the end-to-end encrypted
setting and so it's reasonable to ask
technically speaking what sorts of
properties can we achieve here like what
sorts of moderation can you still even
achieve under encryption and then also
policy-wise what are the pitfalls here
and these two questions reinforce each
other
so one part of this work is a survey of
existing approaches to handling this in
nintend encryption
another part of this work is to
explicitly dig into the policy analysis
and the the encrypted setting really
does pose policy challenges above and
beyond those in standard content
moderation and like i said even normal
content moderation isn't exactly a walk
in the park as far as policy goes
and then that analysis allows us to ask
if any of the myriad policy problems
that we we sort of come up with can be
addressed cryptographically so we built
three protocols we built one signature
scheme to create a route of trust for
the ban list we created an mpc protocol
to ensure that users eventually get
notified of detections
and a one zero knowledge proof that
allows a deployer to show that a
specific image is not banned
um so this is a summary of everything
that i've worked on over the course of
my phd in postdoc i encourage taking a
screenshot before i get cut off here
i've put my email in the upper
right-hand corner
so please feel free to contact me for
any reason whether it's job related or
you just want to chat about this kind of
work thank you
perfect thanks sarah yeah you're uh
you're perfect on time uh next up we'll
go to gavin
gavin brown at boston university
gavin whenever you're ready feel free to
take it away
all right hello my name is gavin brown
i'm a fifth year phd student working in
privacy and machine learning advised by
adam smith
after graduation i hope to complete a
postdoc and obtain a tenure-track
faculty position
in our world of ubiquitous data analysis
we have serious concerns with for
privacy
for instance in this xkcd comic the
revolution is foiled by autocomplete
more mundanely however i might be
concerned that my medical diagnosis will
become public if i participate in a
study
or that participating in the census will
reveal that i'm violating zoning or
immigration laws
these concerns can be formally addressed
by asking the following question which i
view as one of the central question of
my phd
which is what does an algorithm's output
reveal about an individual's data
some of my work focuses on designing
algorithms within the framework of
differential privacy which provides a
formal constraint on how much an
algorithm can reveal about its input
a recent nurbs spotlight paper with
collaborators at bu in northeastern
tackles high dimensional mean estimation
of gaussian distributions under
differential privacy the task here is
to to estimate from data the mean of a
gaussian distribution with unknown
covariance under differential privacy
which informally means that just the out
similar uh
uh data sets must have similar output
distributions for the algorithm
prior work uh suffered from problems due
to
requiring uh prior knowledge on the
covariance matrix or higher sample
complexity than the empirical s
non-private mean estimator
we provide two differentially private
algorithms that compete with the
non-private baseline in terms of sample
complexity the first is a modification
of the gaussian mechanism and the second
is a modification of the exponential
mechanism run over tukey dep
i like these two approaches for
different reasons the first takes a
canonical tool the gaussian mechanism
and extends it beyond the basic clip and
noise paradigm and the second builds on
tools from outside differential privacy
in this case robust statistics another
field that formally models how changing
a few data points can out affect the
output of the learning algorithm i'm
interested in exploring the connections
between these two areas
outside the framework of dp recent work
with collaborators at bu and apple
demonstrated simple learn learning tasks
where accurate learners must memorize
entire training examples
in other words the model must somehow
encode a large fraction of the data it
receives
a result even captures memorization of
irrelevant data information that's
unique to the data set and useless for
classification
our results require
new information complexity lower bounds
for communication games related to the
learning tasks we propose
to supplement our theorems we also have
experiments demonstrating strong
reconstruction attacks against simple
models showing how they directly encode
a large fraction of their training data
looking forward i believe we have only
scratched the surface of this
memorization phenomenon and i'm excited
to understand it in more depth in
particular we have forthcoming work with
similar results in a streaming setting
and our results have implications beyond
just privacy since our mutual
information lower bounds apply space
work space usage requirements
in summary my research motivation can be
written down in two questions
why do complex learning algorithms
sometimes encode large amounts of
information about their inputs
and how can we as algorithm designers
avoid this bad behavior
thank you for listening you can find
links to these and other papers on my
website which is also linked from the
program
thanks gavin perfect timing wow um yeah
next up we have chen wang at rutgers uh
chan feel free to start whenever
you're ready
actually yeah yeah i can see your screen
just fine
okay go ahead let's get started so yeah
so hi everyone i'm chanwan from rutgers
so today i'm going to talk about
myself and my research transcript
probably learning with some linear
algorithms so i'm a fourth year pc
student and rutgers advised by separate
so
i will be on the job market soon as
there is next year and i'm also looking
for research internship like this year
so
my research interest broadly speaking is
inter intersections between machine
learning and tcs this is a broad subset
of things
some topics more computational some
topics more statistical so today i'm
going to emphasize on my work with
formation learning with many algorithms
so
uh the context is that so in the past
decades we have this numerous
breakthroughs some moderate science
machine learning we have these like
normal models like every year but
there's a challenge of learning with
math
so what that what do i mean with
mathematics if you are familiar with
this like machine learning benchmarking
data science you know that's for imaging
machine learning is usually like few
thousand to like ten to the six up to
seven
and graphing machine learning
experiments you reduce few thousand to
few hundred thousand notes
on the other hand
for like many applications like in
google or amazon they have like this
online returning of 350 million lists
for dogs or some stuff graph like the
seventh version isn't into the 10 edges
okay
so this makes the affirmation more than
not like actually applicable
so the challenge here is how to learn
from methods as the rating of storing
the entire input is impossible and we
tackle these possibly algorithms so we
realize that in classical algorithm we
first read and store the input and then
do something something algorithm we work
with resources even smaller than the uh
timer space itself other than the inputs
itself okay so for example if i give you
a graph there is many energies and then
i in some near time algorithm i only
read the ground energy because i don't
care about other edges and you solve the
problem and for a linear space streaming
algorithm i have a memory that is that
is potentially smaller than stream
itself so i only store like very small
things
so i want to highlight 12 results on
this front the first one is streaming
exploration our paper is drinking so we
study this classical pure exploration
you might have been this we give in our
an arms following the vertical
distribution and we want to find the
most rewarding arm which is with the
highest probability to give the reward
okay so the the baltimore summer
complexion has been known for almost
three years but it is like a nr memory
and we introduced a streaming model and
therefore this problem to study the
space deficiency and our result shows
that there exists an algorithm for the
best term with high probability using
the optimal set of a complexity of the
signal okay so we quite i quite like
this result because it's somehow sure
there's no speed somehow traded off in
such a exploration problem
and the second example of this front is
the paper at this conference you study
the correlation clustering with the
disagreement minimization objective okay
so prior to our results best known
results the approximation with the
absolute and square additive error in
order of an uh oh
after square time for seven year time
and a constant approximation uh with
multiple passes over this stream for
this linear space okay so we
we managed to multiply this with a
constant approximation in ultimate end
of time and also we show that there also
with a similar technique there is a
constant population in a single password
data stream okay
so
again i'll be quiet soon and i'm looking
for a internship also and thank you for
attention
perfect yeah thanks so much chun uh this
was great we're good on time uh
next up is damalika mukherjee at purdue
zamalika you can feel free to share
screen and start whenever you feel ready
okay thank you
uh let's see
okay so um this is a really good uh
lineup because my work is actually in
the intersection of the two previous uh
topics so uh i'm tamalika i am advised
by eleanor rescue and jeremiah at purdue
i'm graduating next may and i'll be
looking for a postdoc then
so i want to focus on my current work
which is on differentially private
sub-linear algorithms so as was
mentioned previously
i'll just give a motivation
so here we say you have like a company x
that has massive data sets and uh they
want to run some algorithm to gather
some aggregate statistics about the
users and they want to use the output of
this algorithm to target some population
with their product so in these scenarios
you want
like
polynomial time algorithms may not be
fast enough so you want sublinear
algorithms and you also want to like say
you also want to preserve the privacy of
the users in your data sets so for
example you don't want the output of
this algorithm a to
expose like user one for example uh so
uh the question that we ask
in this motivating example is you know
is there a way for companies to
efficiently gather information but also
preserve privacy of individuals in the
data subsets
so this is where differential privacy
comes in
as i was explaining before
uh differential privacy guarantees that
you will not be affected adversely or
otherwise by allowing your data to be
used in any study or analysis no matter
what other
data sets are available so this notion
is a gold standard in privacy it solves
problems that's faced by anonymizing
data and it also gives you approval
guarantees on privacy
so my work so far and this has been
showing the first results in clustering
for the
that lies in the intersection of being
differentially private and also running
and submitting your time
uh i also have uh another work that is
coming soon that gives the first results
in estimating graph parameters in
sub-linear time and in a differentially
private manner
i previously have also worked on topics
in cryptography
so these are some of the papers that
i've been a part of
and yeah i uh this is pretty short uh
presentation so yeah i'm graduating next
may and uh i'm happy to talk to anyone
who's interested in these works um and
i'm looking for collaborations this year
perfect uh yeah this is well under time
uh thumbelica thanks for that um out of
curiosity what what can you say what
sort of graph parameters you uh try to
estimate
yeah um we have results for estimating
the
size of maximum matching and average
degree of a graph and a size of vertex
cover
cool yeah all right nice thanks uh lika
next up
uh is uh one wrong zhang one wrong is
that harvard please feel free to start
whenever you feel ready one wrong
one wrong are you there
yes i'm here
i'm sure
my slide yeah yeah
um is my screen i can see an empty
screen right now
yeah okay now we can see your slides
perfect go ahead whenever you feel ready
hello um uh my name is
and i'm currently a postdoc in harvard
uh and previously i got my phd from
georgia tech
and i'm looking for 10-year track
faculty positions starting from this
fall
my research focused on the practice
theory and practice of data privacy as
we have already seen previous talk the
field of differential privacy offers
data analysis tools and provides worst
uh powerful worst case privacy
guarantees
and the bulk of my work has been focused
on
privacy preserving statistical tools for
the statistical online decision making
problems
and the second part focus on the data
center leakage properties
and protection because differential
privacy only guarantees the individual
level privacy but it doesn't aim to
protect some population level
information such as the distribution of
race and gender
among users in the trim data set or some
other proprietary information
we give a text showing this machine
learning model can unintentionally
memorize such information and it cause
leakage
and
we also provide methods to against those
attacks including a new privacy notion
and mechanisms to achieve that
and in an ongoing work i'm also
interested in the composition theory of
differential privacy uh specifically the
concurrent composition
and today i'd like to briefly talk about
my work on the attribute privacy and the
concurrent composition
so attribute privacy protects the global
properties of sensitive attributes in
the data set from leaking durian
analysis
so for those of you who are familiar
with differential privacy we are used to
think about the privacy and the
individual level corresponding to the
rules of a database
and in this work we instead consider
privacy of the attributes or columns of
a database
then this will take the view of the
database owner who wishes to publish
aggregate information about
our data sets
but i also want to protect some like
global information like aggregate
information in certain columns for
example in this case the average as a
t-score
we know that as a d score correlated
with sensitive attributes such as race
gender and socio-economic status
and but we wish to hide the average
parent income
whether it's greater than
90k or not
and in this paper we provide
framework and mechanisms to achieve
attribute privacy
and another interesting problem i'm
currently doing this concurrent
composition of
private mechanisms and the previous work
of composition theory focused on the
non-interactive mechanism but
interactive mechanism i needed to
capture many of the intended uh
application like for example when
queries are correlated
and specifically
we consider the concurrent composition
as a motivating example suppose we have
a differentially private query system
and i set a server to answer query
with privacy budget apps
and you also set a server to answer the
query
with epsilon and at first we can do
concurrent attack to such systems and
how do we account for the total privacy
loss
so right now there's uh there's only one
work
uh that gave the compensation theory for
the
pure dp and approximate dp
and
our result gives a concurrent
composition theory for the more general
privacy notion the ftp
thank you thank you for listening and
again here is my
website and you can find the details of
my my papers here
thank you
perfect thanks a lot one wrong
uh
next up is schwann gui huang at
northeastern university uh schwann
feel free to
hi
share screen and uh start whenever you
feel ready okay
can you see the screen
yeah it looks great uh feel free to
start whenever cool hi everyone i'm
shane huang from north season i'm
working with my advisor manuever on
circuit capacity pseudorandomness and
data structural robots i plan to
graduate next year and i'm looking for
an industrial research job
my current research center is around the
power of constant depth circuits it is
well known that parity function cannot
be computed by ac0 the constant that's
boolean circuits we therefore enhance it
with by adding unlayered parities at the
bottom
recently together with my advisor manu
and another
phd student i gave a general template to
construct alpha instructors which is an
important class of distribution is in
pseudo-randomness using this template we
show that we only need that 4 and almost
quadratic size to compute a good alpha
extractor
it is also well known that
majority is not in ac zero
so another way of enhancing it is to
allow majority gains
my result in 2020 showcase its power in
the sense that using tc0 reductions we
can reduce the problem of solving
general immune systems into the problem
of solving some very specially
structured linear systems
and a closely related topic is matrix
rigidity together with manu
we can share explicit functions that is
generally rigid
using techniques like your rectangular
pcp and the famous gas and stats
framework
and another closely related topic is
descriptive complexity by the famous
connection between first order logic and
sdl circuits
and we show that the parameter that the
parameterized version of vertex cover
can be defined with evaluator resources
and
that's all i'm showing huang looking for
industrial research job next year thank
you
thanks uh
that was a very efficient talk
cool next up we have uh ziv scully at
cmu uh if you can feel free to
share and start whenever you feel ready
okay
um
everything appears in order
um okay
all right um hi everyone i'm zev i'm a
phd student at carnegie mellon
graduating soon looking for an academic
position so um i like to hand draw my
slides and on this slide you'll see a
few of the logos from title slides of
previous talks of mine and if you're
curious what this bar of soap and a wine
glass is doing you can come to my itcs
talk later today
okay so at a high level
my research and my interests are
thinking about performance under
uncertainty and performance means lots
of different things in different
contexts and my work is focused on the
specific aspect of delay
specifically in scheduling and queues
and this is an important aspect of
performance because it keeps showing up
so all sorts of situations in your daily
life in computer systems you get delays
and so how do we reduce delays well we
could acquire more resources or we could
invent faster algorithms but that takes
time and effort and money and something
we can do with what we already have is
we can change how we schedule and
and this can really reduce delay but the
theory of scheduling is pretty
underdeveloped compared to what's
happening in practice so i mentioned
uncertainty earlier so something that
happens in practice is um jobs come in
but you don't know the resource
requirements of those jobs
um so how should you schedule under that
type of uncertainty so both in uh this
might be the amount of time jobs take um
also things like the number of servers a
job might occupy so another uh speaking
of multiple servers multi-server systems
um are
are really hard to analyze from a
theoretical perspective even when you
use very simple scheduling policies like
first come from serve
um and then a final uh aspect that's
difficult to attack from a theoretical
perspective is preemption practicalities
it's often helpful when scheduling to
interrupt a job
um and then start serving a different
one but uh theory usually doesn't
account for limitations on when this can
happen or overhead and so in my work i
develop new theoretical tools that help
us attack these sorts of problems
and i'll mention that some of these have
been open for decades in cuba theory um
and so our tools give us the first
results in these in some of these spaces
and so let me tell you about two of
these tools let's open up the toolbox so
the first tool is called soap it's a new
unifying theory of single server
scheduling it unifies not all but lots
of what was previously known about
scheduling in a single server queue and
in addition to unifying it generalizes
it greatly increases the number and
variety of
policies can have
so that's the first tool
the second tool is called wine wine is a
new queueing identity that's in the
tradition of little's law which is this
kind of famous result from uh queuing
that relate that sort of relates the
number of jobs in the system to the
system's delay
and so we come up with a sort of new
friend for little's law that helps us
reduce the analysis of complex systems
to the analyses of related simple
systems
and so we've used soap to
study uh system we've used soap and wine
both in multiple contexts and the one
i'll highlight here is this noisy size
estimates this is scheduling when you
only have a partial information about uh
how long a job takes this is what we do
uh we this is the work for mytcs and i'm
excited about it because it uses both of
these tools
so zooming out where i might like to go
in the future
i'd like to think about other aspects of
performance under under uncertainty um
so some work i've done in this space uh
is i've done some work on combinatorial
optimization under uncertainty that
appeared at ipco um
and then more generally i'd like to i'm
interested in thinking about algorithms
with predictions my itcs work has a bit
of that flavor
and other kind of aspects of
optimization under uncertainty all right
and with that i'll conclude thanks
thanks eve uh yeah i really like the
drawings uh i also like your book about
uh what soap and wine is so you kind of
gave away the suspense here but uh they
should go to your back nonetheless um
next step is uh li jia chen who's at mid
league feel free to
share and go whenever you're ready
um
yeah perfect
yeah so hello everyone i'm lisa chen i'm
currently a fifth year csu student at
mit and i'm advised by professor ryan
whedon and i'll be graduating in some
english summer and after that i'll be
joining you secretly and i'll be looking
for a faculty position after the consort
so i maintain a very broad interest in
theoretical computer science and my work
have spent many different areas today
i'm only going to focus on conditional
complexity theory because that's my
major focus right now and
you can find some summaries of my other
work on my personal website as well
my work in computational complex theory
can be categorized into three lines the
first line works on getting optimal
randomization for kindness assumption so
here we show that one can essentially
get rid of all the
randomness without paying any cost at
all
my second life my work
is on the algorithmic approach to
success which is proposed by my advisor
ryan williams in his life work microsoft
and i use
sophisticated constructions and many
other ideas to prove new skills on
those work includes some new
construction of regional matrices the
first strong average case lower bonds
against acc0
and the first almost everywhere second
lower bounds against x800 so here x0 is
a frontier specific class in complexity
theory for which we all know knowledge
is very limited so this works gives us
more understanding to this frontier
the last line of my work
is on highest magnification the roughly
speaking here we prove in a formal sense
that brexit results such as p not equal
to mp
is stressed when absolute away from what
we can currently pull so maybe we are
not that far away from pulling the
frequency
so next i will talk a bit more on my
life my work on genomization
so here the motivating question is
what's the fastest possible generation
of self-enzyme randomized algorithm here
we use bp time kfn to denote our problem
solvable in randomized kelvin type and
in other words we want a general
transformation which can convert any
kelvin-type randomized algorithm into
equivalent deterministic algorithms
which are as fast as possible
and the classical network shows that one
can be randomized self and time
randomized algorithm without polynomial
overhead but unfortunately the exponent
is very large like seven
that's our original work improved bring
these two quadratics
so in my recent two words with roytel we
proved that under the possible harness
assumptions first tier of
anti-randomized algorithm can be
randomized with only an overhead of n
and this overhead of n is optimal
second we can further randomize
calf and time randomized algorithm with
essentially no overhead and no
polynomial time adversary can find a
mistake so here is not a perfect
generalization because the music
algorithm can still make mistakes but
the catch is that no one can find a
mistake so this so this make it not
subject to the optimality of n mentioned
above and it's still very useful in the
practice
and finally on the technical side we
prove that no black box generation
algorithm like prgs can achieve our
second result so in fact we propose a
new framework for non-black
functionalization to achieve a second
result
yeah that's a tough thing
perfect thanks a lot to ligia
next up is
yazamin nadari at university of
salisbury
okay you see my slides right yep
everything's perfect great
uh so yeah i am yasamin i am
a postdoc at the university of saltsburg
in austria now i work with the western
pursuer and before that i finished my
phd in johns hopkins university where i
worked with mike tinnits
so
let me start by saying that i will be on
academic job market for 10-year track
job soon i will also be open to
related industry research positions
and let me do the reverse thing here and
say that we also have a postdoc opening
in salzburg
and um it's going to be on graph
algorithms and there are a lot of nice
mountains here so join
[Music]
okay
so
my research is
um
whenever i figure out how to go next
okay
mostly on graph algorithms and various
computation models i'm gonna get into
these in a moment
and i also sometimes think about
approximation algorithms and online
algorithms
uh but during my phd i mainly focused on
distances and graphs and in particular
uh distance objects such as hub sets
spanners emulators distance circles
and at a high level
for these objects we are given a graph g
and we want to
store some information about distances
that trade off
um
some
different factors in the original graph
for example uh in case of hopsits we
want to trade up the number of hops on
the shortest paths with
the accuracy of the distances and the
other objects here
are sparse distance specifiers where
they
trade off the accuracy with
the number of edges in
this
f-sub-graph or a
data structure that they
store
okay so um
one of the models that i've recently
been focusing on is dynamic algorithms
where
the input changes over time so in case
of graphs the graphs
change edges can be deleted or inserted
or both
and two of my recent work are
on computing uh the objects i mentioned
then using them for uh computing the
distances in
delete only uh
dynamic models or fully dynamic model
and
i also worked uh
a bit on distributed and parallel
algorithms
um
roughly speaking distributed models are
um
models in which we need to run an
algorithm on a network of sorts with
some different restrictions and
depending on the type of restriction
we're going to have a different
distributed model like local congestive
clique not going to get into details of
those
uh i also talked about the massively
parallel computation model which is
something between the classic parallel
models and this distributed models
and
basically during my phd i worked on
understanding the objects that i
described
in these models and applying them for
computing shortest paths and in some
cases for optimization purposes
um i've
also worked on some other models i'm
going to present the talking itcs today
about virtual tolerance emulators
um
where
the goal is to
construct emulators that can tolerate a
certain number of vertex faults i've
also worked on like classical
approximation algorithms and during an
internship i worked online matching um
and just i want to finish by saying that
i would like to in future
move more toward
optimization combinatorial optimization
and problems industries and dynamic
models and would also like to think
about this existential distance objects
because i think there's still a lot of
interesting open problems
um and that's it please reach out if you
have any questions and comments
perfect thanks uh yasunin um next up is
raghavendra a donkey at umass amherst
raghavendra please feel free to share
and take it away whenever you feel ready
so the other part is sharing the screen
all right you should be good now yeah
yes uh are you able to see my screen
yep loud and clear
uh now not anymore
sorry just
yep
cool we're getting the cat now
okay thanks hi everyone i'm raghavind
radhankhi i'm a finally a phd student at
umass amherst where i am co-advised by
andrew mcgregor and cameron musco
currently i'm looking for post-doc or
industry research positions starting in
the summer
broadly my research contributions can be
categorized into two themes
the first one i've worked
on problems related to causal inference
here i've worked on fundamental problems
such as causal discovery and causal
effect estimation
causal discovery basically deals with
the problem of learning the causal graph
and effect estimation learns
deals with learning the causal effect of
between two variables
here i've also studied approximately
then causal graphs distributed
algorithms for learning causal graphs
and my results have appeared in recent
machine learning conferences
the other major theme of my research is
modern algorithms that is algorithms for
current day systems
here i have studied
various problems such as maximizing
diversity under fairness care and
fairness constraints
how to deal with noise by designing
robust algorithms which are also query
optimal
how to d how to design sub-linear or
dynamic algorithms with changing input
and also search result diversification
in information retrieval
i'll briefly touch upon one of the
results um in each of them
so
in causal discovery the goal is to learn
the causal graph by this i mean we are
given a set of variables this can be
thought of as notes in a graph and we
want to identify the links between them
these are usually directed links and the
goal is to learn a directed acyclic
graph here is an example of a causal
graph which is shown on the right side
underside under certain assumptions um
for the sake of this talk i would not go
into them one can
change the problem into a more discrete
optimization space by
by being
by first detecting the presence of a
causal edge
uh which is shown in the middle unlike
where we have detected that there is a
causal edge
and but we now have to recover the
causal direction
to this we
use to do this we use an fundamental
primitive which is known as an
intervention which
where if we intervene on a subset of
vertices it will allow us to learn all
the directions of edges incident on it
again this is a great simplification but
this
for the for the purpose of today this
suffices so intervening on this s1 will
help us recover the directions
based on this observation and
we can devise a variety of objectives
and i've studied
a few objectives which is minimizing
number of such sets greatly improving on
previous results and devising
distributed algorithms for minimizing
minimizing these number of such sets to
cover the graph if there is a cost
associated i have given approximation
algorithms and showed hardness results
all of these leverage interesting
connections to theory in
such as graph property testing coloring
discrete optimization etcetera
finally i'd like to briefly present
a recent result which is on sublinear
time algorithms recently we have seen a
shift towards these global query models
which overcome the barriers of local
query models in sublinear time local
query model is um is an adjacency list
on adjacency matrix based model here we
are here i've studied graph parameter
estimation where we focused on
estimating number of edges or returning
a uniform sample
and we have studied non-adaptive
algorithms where we ask all the queries
at once uh before even looking at the
graph
the query model which we focused on is
this global query model of bipartite
independent set where we are interested
in detecting the presence of an edge
between the left and the right side
we've showed that just poly login
queries for a relative error
approximation of 1 plus minus epsilon is
sufficient to estimate the number of
edges
[Music]
and that's it
if you want to get in touch here are my
contact details
thank you
thanks uh raghavendra
next up we'll have our last uh presenter
of the session
which is subashri patro
feel free to start whenever you're ready
yes thank you
let me see
is this all visible yes
perfect uh hi i'm sri patro
and my phd project has been uh mostly
about quantum fine grain complexity
um i'm a phd student at just the second
yeah
uh cw like i'm affiliated i'm employed
by cwi and uh affiliated to university
of hampshire
okay um
so let me briefly just talk about
classical fine grained complexity so
that i can give an idea of what we are
doing in the quantum setting
and so fine grain complexity is
mostly about understanding the hardness
of problems within the complexity class
p
so we would like see
we know that in complexity class b we
have problems which are of n square
complexity and cube complexity and
things like that but if we want to know
hardness of a specific problem we um
we we would we would actually like to
know hardness of any specific problem so
for that we and like we we do this fine
grained reductions
and that is we conjecture a lower bound
for some problem a
we reduce problem a to some problem b
and then we conclude a lower bound for
problem b based on this believe blue
upon for problem a
and um
in the classical world uh lower bounds
based on conjectured hardness of c and f
sat threesome apsp orthogonal vectors
are
given
so like uh to summarize this is a
picture from 2015 a server article by
which virginia
v williams but i'm sure most of like a
lot more work would have been added here
and um so in in this you can see that
there are so many problems that was
whose lower bounds were conjectured
based on threesome problem cnf sat
problem or case that problem and a psp
problem and we would like to understand
how these problems behave in the quantum
world
so
in a picture pictorial way like imagine
we have these problems that are in this
complexity class p and we kind of have
an idea of how hard they are in this
world now we would like to understand
how they how hard they are in this bqp
land where uh like by bqp i mean um it's
a
complexity class analogous to uh this
complexity class b yeah okay so problems
that require polynomial time in quantum
world
and uh
so we uh we i like in in my phd we
started uh understanding these
reductions understanding how these
hardness uh
results were established for these each
of these problems
and uh we try to port those things like
put that information to the quantum
world and though in this picture it
seems very easy but actually it was not
a trivial task and we had to go through
a lot of blocks and things like that to
do that
and meanwhile uh there were other group
by arms and at all were also like who
introduced these uh conjectures in the
quantum setting based on the cnf sat
problem
uh we continued our quest for
like understanding hardness or
computational geometry problems and
based on hardness of these three sum
problem in the condom world we gave more
reductions and uh our results were like
very um well accepted by this quantum
community for us
and uh i we expect that by 2003 that's
when uh definitely hopefully i'll
graduate
uh we expect that we will have a lot
more results and a lot more clarity on
how these problems relate in the quantum
setting with each other
uh like to formally summarize my uh
results up till now
so we first gave this um
this
variation of set conjecture in this
quantum world we called it the q set
conjectures so what we so what is set
conjecture set conjecture says that the
c and f sat problem requires to power
and classical time
and a basic u step would be that c and f
sat requires to par n by two quantum
time because we could use grover and we
could speed up this brute force thing
but what we noticed that like many
reductions um just become
trivial and some of them don't are not
even tight so we thought okay what about
what are these reductions doing and we
noticed that these reductions were
actually um
uh
computing a more complicated property
than just finding a satisfying
assignment
and uh grover speed-ups are not amenable
for uh
all of these properties and we realized
that like for some properties like
parity and majority even this q sec like
even the c and f sat problem would take
to power n quantum time and based on
these kind of observations we concluded
these non-trivial bounds for n power 1.5
for edited and lcs which otherwise would
have been just linear bounds if we would
have taken this basic cue set
and
we also feel these these this tricks can
be useful in proving lower bounds for
many other problems especially the
string comparison problems and uh but
there will be the long hanging fruit
that we can explore
and uh after that we also like tried to
understand the sadness of three sum
problem in the quantum setting and we
looked at all these reduction from
threesome problem these computational
geometry problem especially
and uh most of these reductions were
going through a intermediate step where
the inputs were getting spotted now that
is such a trivial thing in classical
setting but in the quantum world it all
would collapse because we don't have a
fast algorithm to um sort
so then we gave a non-trivial uh way to
establish that you sorted threesome in
quantum world also requires end time
just like threesome and that this this
reduction was the crux of our paper that
i we also presented at itcs um and uh
the the reduction went through a work
based reduction and that helped us
establish hardness of sorted threesome
and consequently we gave uh
all like tight linear lower bounds for a
lot of computational geometry problems
and uh
and this was also well accepted in the
quantum community because we will be
talking about it at qip uh in march
um i'm also currently working on some
other problems right now especially
these uh lower bounds that can come from
apsp that is all
shortest path problem um we we have some
work in progress but we we have not
written it up yet so it will take a bit
of time to um for it to be online
but there are other two problems that
i'm working on and which should be
online soon that is we are giving some
more tight bounds for some other
computational geometry problems and
a slightly different area that i also
have worked on is uh in the query
complexity world where we try to give
relate quantum query complexity with
you know decision tree complexity or
some properties on these decision trees
right
so um this is
um about me i'm expected to graduate um
early next year and i'm looking for
postdoc positions either in academia or
in industry
thank you
perfect yeah thanks a lot uh subashri
and uh
yeah thank you to
all the uh presenters today i'm going to
give everyone a little awkward round of
applause sitting here alone by myself um
but yeah we had 11 great speakers today
um yesterday we had another 14. so total
of 25 great uh
young researchers
who presented graduating bits uh if you
missed any of them you can check out
their recordings on youtube
um but yeah thanks for joining and uh
the next session should be starting in
about 10 minutes
thanks everyone and thanks for
organizing this